living in a small island conservation is
a way of life
[Music]
you don't know where your next meal is
could potentially be coming from
the connection for Palance to this land
is so strong I remember going out
fishing with my father and so it's very
important for me to share that same
experience with my two boys
my name is MIA sing about the Minister
of Natural Resources environmental
tourism fishing provides significant
revenue for pallone but because of our
geographic location many illegal fishing
activities come from Southeast Asia
they're invisible to technology that we
have in place
when they do get caught we actually
brand them
this poses a great concern for the
industry here
[Music]
there's two types of licensed fishing
honest or sailing and the other is
longline the main target species are the
guy and yellowfin tuna but throughout
the Pacific tuna has seen a significant
decline over the years
[Music]
the observers really I and Fisheries in
the region we are the ones actually see
what's done on the boat to monitor
compliance within our regions
[Music]
we are part of the crew so we have to
follow the rules on the boat we have to
do what they do
communion this boy I don't speak Chinese
so I just use pen and paper to draw
something now I have to call the chief
Oh captain that's how we communicate
you have to make friends with the crew
so that would you ask for something you
retain they give you back what you asked
for
with some boots with no observers the
misreporting
[Music]
the main issue for the longline fishing
is other marine creatures get caught
accidentally and this is my count
sharks are very important for the
tourism industry they would have a very
important cultural significance for
Allowance as well it's really ingrained
in our culture to protect our
environment for future generations
the pastor fishermen didn't go very far
it could be fishing within two miles of
the shore and actually catch tuna
[Music]
it's taste they would have to work 15 to
20 months he go out in this vast open
water with high waves we've had
incidents of getting lost out in the sea
[Music]
he works more than one month if you
monitor all the sets and appalling
after this trip I go back home then roar
hog market
I'm thinking of quitting after five more
years I'm out for quite a long time
below realize we have very limited
resources so it's important that plowin
children grow up understanding
preserving and conserving resources
[Music]
I want my son's to experience the love
of fishing that I grew up expecially if
they can continue fishing for many years
then I've done my job
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our world's oceans are the only truly
natural renewable resource you add water
light and then the inherent nutrients
that are in the ocean and voila you have
a highly productive system that provides
an incredible amount of protein to feed
the world
my name is Lotus Vermeer I am a marine
scientist with the Nature Conservancy I
work on our Western and Central Pacific
tuna program which is focused on
reducing the bycatch of species
associated with tuna longline fisheries
one out of every seven people rely on
seafood and fish as their primary source
of protein roughly two-thirds of the
world's tuna supply comes from this
region so chances are a high grade
sashimi that you're eating in the
Japanese restaurants or even the tuna
that you're buying in Whole Foods is
coming from these highly productive
waters roughly one-third of the total
catch associated with longline fisheries
in Palau are non-target species millions
of Turtles whales dolphins rays and
sharks
and that's a lot of roadkill on this
undersea highway
[Music]
[Music]
we're conducting research fishing trials
that are all focused on the question can
we reduce bycatch and still maintain
acceptable catch levels of tuna the
Nature Conservancy's charted a longline
vessel for about a year a year and a
half and we've done that in partnership
with our key industry partner loon Thai
seafoods we made this day and a half
long journey and we were able to find in
the middle of nowhere this fishing boat
that we are working with and for me it
was just incredible moment
with this partnership we have with the
Nature Conservancy we're looking at our
longline industry interesting different
methods to see if we can catch less
charge in lessen the impact of the white
house can we reduce bycatch by using
wider hooks
[Music]
the Sharks
biting adverb a with
Minister sang about is the very close
and ally in fisheries reforms for me was
absolutely critical that the Minister be
able to experience this firsthand and
see what's going out in his waters
the tuna fishing industry is a very
important industry for the Pacific
Islands and Palau as well I'm hoping
that some of the experiments that
they're putting forward is actually
ilding less of the bycatch
[Music]
you know we we don't have huge land mass
we don't have the oil reserves like the
Middle East this is our oil tuna is our
oil and unless we manage it right we
could lose this industry in the future
we need to make sure that our impact is
managed in a way that we can sustain the
future of our ocean
ultimately my hope is that we can ensure
that our work here will result in
significant and fundamental reductions
in bycatch
and not just in the territorial waters
of Palau this small nation could really
be the catalyst for marine conservation
reform all around the world
[Music]